with limitless potential in the deepest
pockets in showbusiness working for it
one wonders when certain beloved and in
some cases obscure and downright bonkers
Marvel comics storylines will work their
way onto Disney Plus here are a few
crazy Marvel stories we hope will soon
hit the small screen it's no secret that
Netflix's iron fist had its problems it
lacked the grit of daredevil the
intrigue of Jessica Jones or the charm
of Luke Cage however those that stuck
around to the end of the second and
final season well know his storyline was
poised to get into some pretty fun and
super mystical territory as the
character never failed to mention he was
the immortal iron fist tasked with
protecting the magical city of Kunlun
but it was hinted that Conlan wasn't the
only magical city worth protecting
Kunlun it's one of the seven capital
cities of heaven probably never should
have left in the comics dandy status as
the iron fist makes him the perfect
champion to represent Kunlun in the
tournament to the seven capital cities
of heaven see iron fist home is just one
of seven cities that converge every 88
years for a good old-fashioned Mortal
Kombat style fighting tournament
although iron fist may not have been the
best show in the ill-fated Marvel
Netflix partnership it was at its best
when it was showing off cool fight
scenes and even cooler characters
adapting the seven capital cities of
heaven storyline would basically offer
the character we know a bevy of
opportunities to fight fight concept
martial arts masters with powers and
gimmicks of their own now there's a lot
of stuff about portals world domination
and the politics of heavenly cities if
the studio can see fit to bring any of
the defenders back this story might be
the way to go Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe is pretty straightforward in
that it's just what it sounds like the
talkative Wade Wilson that we all know
and love becomes just a little more
unhinged and makes it his mission to
kill literally every superhero and super
villain in the galaxy and honestly we
think it would make for a pretty awesome
Disney Plus show after all part of what
makes Ryan Reynolds Deadpool movies so
appealing is their irreverence in the
face of a superhero genre that often
takes itself too seriously now thanks to
the Disney Fox deal the actor has
already said he's working on a third
Deadpool project with the fellas over at
the MCU what better way to introduce the
fourth wall breaking character to his
new superhero family than with a cannon
defying romp where he battles
every single one of them it may sound
dark but that darkness is what makes the
comic story line so fun
Deadpool uses Pym particles to blow up
most of the Avengers the truth about his
reality causes Professor X to go brain
dead and even battles Wolverine while
wearing beasts Hyde is a furry cape it's
over-the-top sure but it's the perfect
way for Wade Wilson's self-aware
antihero to enter the MCU and have a
little meta fun in the process
obviously the plan wouldn't be to leave
spider-man with a bullet in his head
like the comic does but with the what-if
cartoon and the time-travel elements of
infinity warren and game on the table
anything can happen as long as it's fun
that tickets gratuitous but whatever The
Hulk has mainly served as a supporting
character in the other heroes stories
for the past few years but a reimagining
of World War Hulk with banner taking the
spotlight would fit the MCU perfectly
the story is sparked by Tony Stark Reed
Richards dr. strange and others deciding
the only safe thing to do for Humanity
is to banish the Hult from Earth however
when someone Holt cares about is killed
in the process he manages to return to
the planet vowing revenge on the heroes
who sent him away and caused the whole
mess the MCU has hinted several times in
the past that the Hulk's power is
limitless in the event Bruce Banner
loses control and gets really angry
giving the character a chance to finally
take the lid off and go toe-to-toe with
a hero who isn't Thor would satisfy a
question Marvel fans have wondered for
years could the Hulk be stopped by our
heroes and villains if they needed to
Thor knocked him out once and Tony Stark
won on a technicality but that was
before Bruce Banner embraced his big
green alter ego a Hulk that's both
savage and smart like the one we see in
world war hulk would be a lot more than
they bargained for there's a small but
vocal contingent of fans who believe the
Hulk didn't get his fair shake in the
movies adapting the World War Hulk
storyline could satisfy that group in a
big violent hurry Plus what's better
than a whole bunch of MCU hulk fights
nothing that's what
after the first guardians of the galaxy
movie dealt so heavily with the Nova
Corps many believed that the
introduction of Richard Ryder the
classic Nova the comics wasn't far
behind and in Avengers infinity war it's
revealed that the planet Zander which
housed the Nova Corps was destroyed by
Thanos a similar event happens in the
comic books
setting the lone surviving member of the
Nova Corps on a journey
to introduce one of the most powerful
Comics superheroes so why should Nova's
epic story be adapted for Disney Plus
simply puts guarding into the galaxy wet
bands appetites for more stories set in
the cosmic reaches of the Marvel
Universe some of the strangest and most
important comics take place on the
fringes of the Marvel galaxy and since
the third guardians film is set to bring
Peter Quill's story to an end we need
someone else out there exploring the
vast reaches of the cosmos so perhaps
it's time to open the space travel doors
in a way that's both accessible to the
audience and that expands the universe
even more this doesn't even run the risk
of brushing up against the main
storyline in the movie since it's a lot
easier to miss something going on in the
far reaches of the galaxy then in say
lower Manhattan
overall the possibilities are endless if
we're being honest no character fared
worse in the translation from the pages
of Marvel comic books to the big screen
than Scott Summers when he wasn't
playing second fiddle to Wolverine in
Jean Grey he was being unceremoniously
killed off screen meanwhile his comic
counterparts is not only a capable and
principled leader but he often operates
as the voice representing the mutant
community in conversations with fellow
team leaders like Iron Man mr. fantastic
Black Panther and more so since the
x-men movies failed summers in every way
possible maybe it's time to seize the
opportunity provided by Disney Plus to
remove him from the x-men and just do
some cool stuff with a guy that can
shoot concussive force blasts out of his
eyes for example Disney Plus could take
the story from 2014 where a time display
Cyclops finds his way to space and goes
on an adventure with his father who we
thought to be deceased better still he
finds out that his dad as a freakin
space pirate putting Cyclops in the
cosmos would not only help remove him
from the x-men but it would put him
where he belongs on the playing field
with other major recognizable characters
Marvel can take all the time it needs to
figure out how to bring x-men and
mutants into the MCU while that happens
maybe it's a good look for the new
owners to rectify the mistakes made to
one of its most beloved characters by
the past movies and give Cyclops his own
story if we've learned anything from pro
wrestling video games and even the MCU
itself it's that there's nothing better
than a battle royale with a ton of
characters taking each other on in
no-holds-barred combat
in 1984 the Marvel Universe staged its
very own all-hands-on-deck Rumble with
the secret war storyline it saw being
known as the Beyonder gather a
collection of Earth's greatest heroes
and villains on a planet not so subtly
named battle world it was also one of
the most popular comics at the time as
it marked the first major crossover
event in Marvel history while the Marvel
Cinematic Universe eventually evolved
into series of incredibly well-executed
crossover events secret Wars has still
got a lot that fans would love to see
with the x-men in the Fantastic Four
being incorporated into the MCU we could
get the entire universe of Marvel Comics
together on screen for the very first
time the original secret war spawned a
couple of direct sequels including one
where no kidding the Spider Man had to
teach the Beyonder how to use the
bathroom but in 2015 they put a new spin
on the concept also called Secret Wars
the story saw Marvel characters from
different universes crossing over with
one another while the multiverse
logistics would need some polishing a
cosmic level event or a beam like the
Beyonder might provide a quick and easy
way for mutants to suddenly be around
borås Dark Tower to somehow become the
Baxter building without a lot of origin
story mess
Disney Plus gives the MCU a rare
opportunity to play with its own mythos
without the ultra high stakes of a major
blockbuster release the original Secret
Wars caught some criticism for its
somewhat simplistic writing but it
helped usher in the world of major comic
crossover events at the MCU perfected in
many ways the world of the MCU can be
split into pre and post Civil War eras
he's my friend
so was I it not only divided our heroes
until Thanos launched his attack and
became an unavoidable threat but aborts
all of the Avengers to grapple with a
serious moral question and to take sides
accordingly in 2016 the comics tried to
recapture that magic by starting a
similar conflict between Iron Man and
Captain Marvel and civil war - and that
story would make for a pretty
interesting Disney Plus feature however
with Iron Man not in the best of health
these days the leader of the second
faction could be anyone and the point
would remain the same
in short the plot focuses on an inhuman
named Ulysses who has visions of the
future
Captain Marvel sees this as the ticket
to stopping horrible events before they
happen Tony Stark meanwhile doesn't
believe in taking pre-emptive measures
to bring about peace that provides the
moral line in the sand that characters
have to take sides on bike the sokovia
accords it provides every hero in the
Marvel Universe with a reason to not
only take sides but fight well there
aren't many Tony Stark level
replacements in the MCU that could take
on Captain Marvel
there are several principled heroes like
Spider Man Hawkeye Bruce Banner and Thor
who could believably stand up for the
rights of people to not be punished for
something that didn't yet do with so
many new characters joining the fold
it's time to get to know them in a trial
by fire setting once again in the 1990
crossover event extinction agenda
various mutants from different teams are
forced to come together when they face
an extinction level event when the
island of Genosha ramps up its
effectiveness as a mutant enslavement
empire even enemies of the x-men are
forced to worry about its power growing
the story sees estranged heroes reunite
for the first time in years to form a
new team and combat the growing threat
although the comic story really gets
into the weeds with its complications it
has some great action moments and could
do a great job of introducing not just
the mutants but the world that hates and
fears them despite its very 90s
trappings extinction agenda has pretty
much everything you'd want from an x-men
story from dynamic action to the
metaphor of the x-men fighting society
for the right to exist in shorts
adapting the storyline could give
audiences a crash course in the x-men
how the world views them and what they
can offer to change it all together in
one tight storyline check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stop
or coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]